the M1 Abrams entered service in 1980 a
fast heavily armored tank with the very
latest Technologies to give it every
advantage on the battlefield first scene
action in Operation Desert Storm the
plane arid camouflage tank gained a
reputation quickly in the barren deserts
of Saudi Arabia and Kuwait powered by a
high-speed turbine engine the M1 raced
across this difficult terrain to
liberate Kuwait from Iraqi occupation
the German designed 120 millimeter
smoothbore cannon had longer range more
accurate fire and more advanced
ammunition it easily dispatched the
lower Tech Soviet Supply tanks of the
Iraqi Army sometime this year it's
expected that the US will deliver a
battalion of 31 M1 Abram tanks to
Ukraine to once again face off against
the Soviet tanks it was designed to
battle the Ukrainian Army will need
training to maintain and operate these
new tanks because they are like no other
tank and although this tank is over 40
years old it's still more than capable
of holding its own on the battlefield
thanks to continual modernization and
forward-thinking Design This is the
insane engineering of the M1 Abrams
[Music]
the M1 Abrams upon engine startup sounds
more like a military aircraft getting
ready to take off
a terrifying increasing pitch as the
engine revs up to speed
the whirring sound emanating from the
rotating turbine blades hidden inside
the turbine engine typically used for
jet aircraft is an engine designed for
high speed operation with minimal waste
a counter-intuitive choice for a heavy
battle tank so why was it chosen the
turbine engine would give the M1 two
huge advantages they are much lighter
than an equivalent diesel engine
weighing just 1.1 tons and developing 1
500 brake horsepower the V12 diesel
engine of the Challenger 2 produces 1
200 brake horsepower with two tons of
metal this compactness and extreme high
power to weight ratio allows the M1 to
stack on layers of armor without
sacrificing acceleration or top speed
we can plot torque versus shaft speed of
the Honeywell
agt1500 turbine engine of the M1 against
the V12 MTU 883 of the Challenger 2E and
we can see the turbine has a massive
torque Advantage at lower shaft speeds
in its lightest configuration the M1
weighs 61.8 tons a typical Toyota
Corolla weighs 1.1 ton that's equivalent
to 56 Toyota Corollas yet this thing can
accelerate from 0 to 32 kilometers per
hour in just 7 seconds with a top speed
of 72 kilometers per hour
the M1 Abrams primarily uses diesel fuel
as diesel can act as an additional layer
of armor liquids are extremely good at
absorbing energy from explosions and
kinetic energy weapons they are most
effective against shaped charges and
tanks carry a lot of liquid in the form
of fuel it may seem counter-intuitive to
use fuel as protection from an explosion
but diesel fuel is not very flammable in
fact if you throw a lit match into a
bottle of diesel it will put the match
out diesel engines require immense
pressure and a sustained flame to ignize
because of this diesel can be used with
relative safety as armor however the
turbine engine can also operate on most
fuel types this is a huge advantage in
military logistics making joint
operations with NATO vastly easier in
the Years following World War II the
Soviets favored diesel compression
ignition engines the Western allies used
a mixture of both gasoline spark
ignition and diesel compression ignition
transporting fuel is one of the largest
logistic challenges in war needing
several types of fuel makes it all the
more difficult the M1 can run on marine
diesel gasoline or even kerosene if
needed which not only makes it easier to
procure fuel in a war zone but Combs
with the added bonus of helping the M1
operate in hot or cold weather dealing
with the wild swings and temperature
that Ukraine can expect throughout the
year with ease where diesel fuels can
crystallize at low temperatures kerosene
can be used instead the turbine engine
of the M1 Works similarly to aircraft
engines with some important differences
air enters the engine here where it is
compressed by the low pressure
compressor and then the high pressure
compressor each individually driven by
separate turbine stages these turbine
stages are driven by the combustor which
works a little differently to typical
aircraft combusters it is mounted
perpendicularly to the engine and
protrudes out of the engine this makes
maintenance access to the combustor
easier with only a simple bolted cover
needed to be removed there are two drive
shafts in this engine a secondary drive
shaft driven by the high pressure
turbine which runs forward to an
accessory gearbox that runs things like
compressors electronics and hydraulics
the main drive shaft driven by a
dedicated power turbine which is not
connected to the compressors runs
rearward to the Tank's Drive sprockets
this primary drive shaft and its
reduction gearbox is surrounded by
something called a recuperator this is
the biggest difference between this
turbine engine and a typical aircraft
jet engine we don't want the hot exhaust
of this engine spewing out like a jet
engine the Heat Signature this would
create would be a joint Beacon for heat
guided missiles and give the Tank's
location away to any enemy using thermal
vision we we also don't want to waste
all that heat energy the recuperator is
essentially a giant heat exchanger air
coming from the compressor stage is
passed through it where it is heated by
the exhaust before entering the
combustion chamber this lowers the heat
signature of the exhaust and increases
fuel efficiency transferring more heat
energy back into the engine instead of
losing it to the atmosphere but the M1
Abrams is still a thirsty machine even
by Tank standards the turbine engine
uses twice the fuel as a comparable
diesel engine per kilometer where the
M1A1 consumes around 4.2 liters per
kilometer while cruising at 40
kilometers per hour the leper 2 consumes
2.2 liters per kilometer but the U.S
military deemed this issue a cost worth
paying for the capabilities the turbine
engine provided allowing the M1 to carry
an obscene amount of armor while keeping
its acceleration High
the armor installed on the M1 Abrams has
evolved and changed over the past four
decades the exact details of its
thickness location materials and
layering is classified for obvious
reasons but there is a great deal known
about the science and nature of its
armor it is well publicized that early
M1 variants used a type of composite
ceramic armor called choppum which
derives much of its ballistic resistance
from an extremely hard and light ceramic
layer hardness in Material Science is a
measure of a material's ability to
resist localized deformation like a
scratch diamonds are extremely hard and
because of this industrial diamonds are
coated onto cutting tools to help them
cut through materials without being
eroded themselves a hard material can
scratch and erode a softer material
hardness can be measured with a Vicar's
hardness test which pushes a
pyramid-shaped diamond into the material
the hardness is then calculated by
dividing the force applied by the
resulting surface area of the
indentation
the rolled homogeneous armor steel of
World War II has a Vicar's hardness test
of 380 a high carbon steel is about 550
while a ceramic like Silicon carabite
offers a hardness five times greater up
to 2500 while being much lighter than
steel making it an excellent candidate
for armor but anyone that has dropped a
dinner Place knows that Ceramics are
extremely brittle they shatter into a
million pieces with little Force but
this can be used to the Tank's Advantage
when combined with a tougher metal
backing place in this configuration the
ceramic is placed on the outside of the
metal plating acting like an extremely
hard outer shell when a round strikes
the hammer the compressive strength and
hardness of the ceramic coating causes
the round to fracture and break apart at
the same time the ceramic coating begins
to fracture in fragment spreading the
energy of impact across a larger area
which is then absorbed by the tougher
metal plate backing the ceramic tough in
Material Science means it can absorb a
lot of energy without fracturing the
opposite of brittle further research and
experimentation found ceramic armor
performed even better when placed under
compression this can be achieved by
simply adding a face plate and bolting
the two pieces together this changes the
Dynamics of an impact significantly and
helps immensely with resisting attack
from Long Rod kinetic energy projectiles
these are rounds specifically designed
As anti-amer Weapons they are thin long
dart-like projectiles that require a
Sabo to launch out of tank barrels they
are typically manufactured from high
density materials like tungsten with a
thin aerodynamic shape and high density
these weapons have an extremely high
ballistic coefficient allowing them to
Ram into targets at a distance at high
velocities they can obliterate rows of
concrete walls with ease embedded
compressed ceramic armor can defeat
these kinetic energy weapons when when
the Long Rod projectile strikes the
faceplate it sends a pressure wave
through the ceramic that pulverizes it
and increases its volume this creates
what is essentially an abrasive Maze of
extremely hard and sharp particles the
penetrator has to push through gradually
grinding it away computer simulations of
this effect show that the harder the
material the better this is the magic of
ceramic composite armor on top of these
metal and ceramic layers there is
typically a very dense inner liner
called a spa lining projectiles don't
necessarily need to penetrate every
layer of armor to be deadly if they hit
with enough Force the kinetic energy can
simply transfer through the material as
a wave and cause material on the inside
of the tank to Splinter and turn into
deadly shrapnel inside the crew
compartment this is called spall some
Munitions are specifically designed to
cause this high explosive squash heads
are made from soft plastic explosives
that spread out over the the Armor's
surface with the increased surface area
and direct contact with the armor the
explosion transfers a great deal of
energy through the material and blows
out the Armor's backing this works by
sending a compressive shock wave through
the material and reflects and rebounds
inside the material creating regions of
intense stress that fractures the armor
the spa liner is a ductile and dense
material that limits spalling for early
m1s this layer was typically composed of
lead but beginning in 1988 certain m1a1s
began to be upgraded with depleted
uranium Spa liners which are even denser
than lead and all new m1a2s were
assembled with depleted uranium liners
however modern composite armor makes it
difficult for the shock wave to transmit
through the material and a space layer
with an air gap can defeat this squash
adminition completely additional
reactive armor tiles can be added to the
outside of the M12 reactive armor is
particularly effective at dealing with
shaped charges shaped charges consist of
a charge shaped with a hollow
indentation lined with a ductile metal
liner when the charge is detonated a
pressure wave forms behind the metal
liner deforming it and accelerating the
metal into a lance-like stream of
particles the shape charge effectively
creates a Hypersonic projectile at
point-blank range it's highly effective
at cutting through armor reactive armor
works by placing an explosive charge
between two metal plates when a jet from
a shaped charge strikes the upper plate
it detonates the inner explosive you may
think this could damage the tank but the
Tank's lower armor is more than capable
of dealing with the relatively blunt
pressure formed by the reactive armor
detonation the outer plate then flies
outwards to disrupt the incoming jet
while the shock wave formed by the
detonation also breaks up the stream of
metal approaching the tank
of course the best defense is to not be
hit at all and the M1 can create a smoke
screen for itself when needed the M1 has
two systems for generating smoke to
conceal itself in an engagement the
first involves simply spraying fuel into
the engine exhaust which vaporizes the
fuel and creates a large opaque Cloud
behind the tank however it's extremely
important that the driver remembers
which fuel the tank is running on this
works for diesel fuel but if gasoline or
kerosene is used it won't conceal the M1
it will set it on fire
the second system uses grenade launchers
mounted on the outside of the turret
there are two versions the M1 uses the
eight canister m257 typically used with
the US Marine Corps m1s and the more
widely used 6 can m250 these launchers
are controlled from the tank commander
seat here pressing one button launches
six grenades three from the left and
three from the right pressing both
buttons launches all 12 of the grenades
launching them about 30 meters from the
tank and providing a shrouding curtain
of smoke to hide its movements the
engineers of the M1 Abrams did
everything in their power to make the M1
as survivable as possible protecting the
crew inside and the highly trained crew
are the most important part of this
machine the M1 Abrams does not have an
automatic loader like many modern tanks
it has a dedicated crew member the
loader to load rounds into the breach
Auto loaders are a feature of modern
Russian tanks however the USA have shown
them in their
seen an autoloader as an unnecessarily
complex mechanism that would impact the
m1's reliability seeing a fourth crew
member capable of keeping watch
maintaining the vehicle and taking over
responsibilities in an emergency as an
advantage not a disadvantage the loader
enters the tank through the turret hatch
sitting to the left of the main gun with
access to the ammunition box behind them
the Gunner to the right is in charge of
aiming at Targets using these day and
thermal night vision sights along with a
laser range finder to input Target
distances into the ballistic computer
when instructed by the tank commander
sitting behind the Gunner the loader
will press a switch with their knee to
open a hydraulically actuated armored
door behind them the tank commander will
specify the round needed and the loader
will take it out load it into the breach
close the bridge and move the safe
handle into the Armed position this
process will be repeated until a
ceasefire is called by the tank
commander the air mode ammunition access
door is only open when loading and this
is crucial for the survivability of the
M1 Abrams if a round penetrates the
ammunition box it can result in a lethal
detonation of the ammunition stored
inside this armored door is capable of
withstanding this blast and panels on
top of the tank called blowout panels
are designed to break and allow the
pressure and heat to be directed upwards
and away from the crew these rounds are
fired out of the m1's 120 millimeter
cannon early m1s were fitted with a 105
millimeter cannon 105 referring to the
bore diameter of the gun this decision
was made primarily to allow a sharing of
ammunition and parts between the 105
millimeter on the previous generation
M60 tank with the development of
depleted uranium rounds it was viewed
that this gun was more than adequate to
deal with any Soviet armor however U.S
allies like Germany did not want to use
depleted uranium rounds due to ethical
implications and were moving towards 120
millimeter cannons with the British
Chieftain tank using the Royal Ordnance
l11 and the German Leopard 2 using the
Rhine metal rh-120 this posed a problem
for NATO's goals of standardizing
wherever possible to optimize Logistics
with ammunition factories across NATO
countries producing the same ammunition
this ensured ammunition could not only
be shared but manufactured as close to
the front line as possible the 120
millimeter guns of the M1A1 and m1a2 are
in fact German Rhine metal rh-120s
manufactured under license in the US a
5.3 meter long 3.3 ton smoothbore Cannon
this large bulge in the middle of the
cannon is designed to evacuate the
barrel of propellant gases after each
firing once the round leaves the barrel
atmospheric pressure can prevent the
gases from leaving and once the breach
is opened the potentially harmful and
explosive gas can enter the crew
compartment
the bore evacuator is a pretty simple
solution with holes that allow gases to
enter the evacuator as the round passes
by this acts like a pressure Reservoir
when a round leaves the barrel with this
attachment the pressure is released from
the forward-facing holes at the far end
of the evacuator and this pushes the
remaining gases outwards the two primary
rounds used by the M1 are the m829
depleted uranium round which is a sabode
kinetic energy round and the
m830a1 heat round which despite its name
does not use heat as part of its
offensive it uses a kinetic energy
shaped charge
we have been piling on weight in this
vehicle the armor Cannon engine and
ammunition makes this an extremely heavy
vehicle weighing between 52 and 68 tons
depending on the generation and
configuration the M1 Abrams needed a
track and suspension system capable of
bearing that waste for a vehicle this
heavy typical helical Springs have some
problems first their maximum travel is
limited at a particular load the layers
of a helical spring will meet and no
further travel is possible bottoming out
and providing an extremely uncomfortable
ride for the crew to deal with a heavier
vehicle we need to increase the spring
coil diameter taking up an increasing
amount of space this was an issue for
World War II era tanks with the M4
Sherman opting to use a Volute spring
which is a conical spring that is
capable of compressing to a much smaller
size as the sheets of spring steel
overlap however most modern tanks
utilize the torsion spring which take up
very little space inside the tank though
they do raise the Tank's height
considerably the torsion springs of the
M1 are located here and because they are
inside the hull they raised the whole
height by 150 millimeters the road wheel
is attached to a lever which can travel
up and down this lever arm is attached
to the torsion bar so that it twists
when the lever arm moves up and down the
spring force is derived from the Bear's
resistance to torsion older tanks
incorporating torsion bars had limited
travel the m1's predecessor the M60 had
a wheel travel of just 20 centimeters
during the development of the M1 the two
tanks were pitted against each other
with the M1 benefiting from 20 years of
Material Science progress its Max travel
was nearly double that of the M60 at 38
centimeters when tested on a track with
a series of 30 centimeter bumps at 32
kilometers per hour the M60 managed to
break its front wheels lost control and
broke the driver's arm the torsion
spring of the M1 runs along the width of
the hull making them quite heavy we need
the torsion spring to be as long as
possible because the travel distance is
a function of the torsion barish length
longer torsion bars can twist more
before braking an interesting Quirk of
the torsion spring system is that
typical designs like the m1s mean that
the road wheels cannot be aligned we
cannot connect the lever arms of
opposite road wheels to the same torsion
spring as they would frequently travel
together creating no torsion the far end
of the bar needs to be rigidly mounted
to the body of the tank in order to
develop a spring Force so two torsion
bars need to be mounted alongside each
other creating an offset in distance
between the two sides of the tracks the
two sides of the M1 are not symmetrical
this comes with some drawbacks the
leading road wheel will hit bombs first
meaning it will absorb more Force than
the trailing road wheel increasing the
wear on the leading torsion spring is
resulting in more frequent Replacements
torsion bars are very easy to swap out
when they aren't Broken But if bent or
shattered or if the body of the tank is
bent it can be difficult to pull the
long torsion springs out modern tanks
are increasingly moving towards Hydro
gas suspensions which look like this the
road wheel has an attached axle pivot
arm which in turn turns a crank and a
conrod piston this piston connects to a
hydro gas suspension cylinder the first
chamber is filled with a fluid typically
oil the oil is relatively incompressible
and so provides marginal spring Force
but this chamber has a damper valve that
serves to restrict the transfer of fluid
between this chamber and the next which
contains a floating piston with a
compressed nitrogen gas on the other
side this provides the spring Force to
ensure the road wheels stay in contact
with the ground but also dampens out
vibrations this system is much smaller
lighter and easier to service than
torsion bar virus while lowering the
height of the tank lowering its profile
and making it harder to hit not only
that but each individual suspension can
be remotely adjusted by changing the gas
pressure inside the cylinder allowing
the tank to take a Crouch position if
needed Hydro gas suspensions were
considered for the M1 during development
but it was a relatively new technology
at the time and so the torsion spring
was chosen the M1 Abrams has had
incremental improvements added over the
past four decades with three primary
variants the M1 M1A1 and the m1a2 with
even more specialized iterations in
between with updated sensors and
controls to bring the tank into the 21st
century like the crows 2 on the m1a2 SCP
SCP standing for systems enhancement
package which added additional thermal
sights for the tank commander and
auxiliary power unit to run its
Electronics without running the fuel
hungry engine and the cross 2 controller
a remote control site that allows the
tank commander to operate the gun from
the safety of the turret we are
currently on the m1a2 scp-v4 variant and
the Army is considering the future of
the M1 program whether that's the m1a2
scp-v5 or a completely new platform but
make no mistake despite the M1 being one
of the longest serving tanks in a modern
military over four decades old it's
still highly capable and will be a
massive asset to the Troops on the
ground in Ukraine the next episode of
real engineering is about the incredible
physics behind magnetic resonance
imaging it will be out on YouTube in two
weeks but maybe you want to prepare in
advance to better understand what we
talk about MRI machines use a pretty
incredible property in Ace to our body
tissues the quantum spin of hydrogen
atoms and how they interact in different
tissue types it took us a long time to
write this script understanding quantum
mechanics is hard third and quantum
physics is becoming increasingly
relevant in everyday engineering from
magnetic resonance imaging to Quantum
Computing brilliant has three courses to
get you started with understanding this
scientific concept it's powerful
knowledge to obtain and you can complete
a course for free by signing up at
brilliant.org forward slash real
engineering getting started on your
first course is completely free for the
first 30 days but the first 500 people
that sign up with our link will get 20
off brilliant's annual premium
subscription brilliant makes learning
fun and interesting with bite-sized
interactive lessons that make it easy to
jump in and out of courses so you can
learn in your own time and it's even
easier with their mobile app so you
could learn the fundamentals of computer
science on your morning commute to work
or school brilliant includes interactive
elements to help you quickly understand
Concepts and test your knowledge along
the way to ensure sure you are
understanding the concepts you are
learning brilliant focuses on
facilitating Effective Education that
will help you progress in your learning
goals whether it's professional career
advancement or just for fun for lifelong
Learners bringing their adding content
monthly so there's always something new
to learn you can get started for free
for the first 30 days by clicking the
link on screen right now and the first
500 people to do so will get 20 off
brilliant annual premium subscription